also tonight ccsd leaders talking about  a recent uptick in school violence  during tonight's regular board meeting  solutions and future plans were laid out  including possibly an increase in school  police staffing and expansion of  services through current programs and  student discipline but one parent we  spoke with tonight says he still wants  more done  how many times we've seen the school  district have these meetings and then we  have them again and nothing happens we  have all the casinos entertainment  capital but yet our children are being  left behind basically  a 400 thousand dollar grant was also  approved tonight to allow police and  social workers to organize at home  visits for at-risk students